HOV lanes tend to be a lot faster if
you're someone who gets to use them
often but soon all drivers will be able
to get on them throughout the night
starting October 24th changes are coming
to the major highways in the valley HOV
lanes will operate 5 a.m to 10 p.m for
cars with more than one person inside
and 10 pm to 5 a.m for all drivers
ultimately you know really we want to
encourage as many people as possible to
use the HIV Lanes Justin Hopkins with
ndot says this new pilot program is
aimed to help lessen the traffic we see
on the roads he says HOV lane users can
get to their destination faster and this
new pilot program is to encourage
drivers to start carpooling more the HOV
system really ramps up just before 5 a.m
and it stays pretty consistent during
the day with regard to the general
purpose Lanes the pilot program stems
from a study and Dot has been conducting
for over a year to see how frequently
the HOV lanes get used the most
currently the HOV lanes are 24 7 for
cars with multiple passengers First
Responders and motorcyclists I
definitely use the HOV feeling whenever
it can some drivers like Scott
hugelmeyer say they like the new changes
in the HOV lanes I think that would
really help we have different hours here
in Vegas so it'll it'll be interesting
to see how that works we don't have like
a normal Rush Hour type nine to five
again this change will take place on
October 24th along I-15 and us-95 this
is just a pilot program so Enda will be
reviewing again and again 18 months
Victoria Saha eight news now